September 22, 1926.
Howard Carter and his team begin
their fifth excavation season
at the tomb of King Tutankhamun.
The focus of their work
is an unwalled room
on the far end of the burial
chamber called the treasury.
When they enter, the
first thing they come upon
is a fifth so-called
magic brick.
This fifth brick has
a harrowing inscription
that reads, it is I who
hindered the sand from choking
the secret chamber.
And who repel that
one who would repel
him with the desert flame.
I have set aflame the desert.
I have caused the
path to be mistaken.
I am for the protection
of the deceased.
And we have to wonder,
why was this brick
placed in the tomb Tutankhamun?
While other pharaoh's
tombs were found
to contain four magic
cursed bricks, only
King Tut's includes a fifth.
But why?
That fifth brick may
be a clue, a sort of X
marks the spot treasure
map that shows us
that something very
significant that perhaps
we still don't understand
was hidden in that tomb.
On September 28, 2015, British
Egyptologist, Nicholas Reeves,
made a remarkable discovery
while examining high resolution
scans of King Tut's tomb--
the possibility
of hidden cavities
within the burial chamber.
Dr. Reeves looked at high
resolution images of this wall
and he noticed a crack
that looks like it
should have been a door.
And it was right about here.
They brought
thermal scanners in
and scanned behind this wall.
And they believe
they found cavities
behind this specific area.
He took a permission to
go inside the north room
and dig through to discover
what's behind this wall.
Just a couple of months
before the mission took place,
it was stopped for
unknown reasons.
Who or what maybe hidden
in this secret chamber
is hotly debated.
But some researchers believe
it is possible that it contains
the remains of Egypt's
most controversial
pharaoh, Akhenaten,
who also happens
to be the father of King Tut.
Ancient Egypt had always
been polytheistic, many gods.
And then there as a new leader,
a new pharaoh with a new idea.
Akhenaten announces
there will be one god.
They will be a
monotheistic people.
Aten, the sun god, would be the
one deity they all worshipped.
The image is the sun disk.
It shook the empire in
really terrible ways.
What could have
inspired Akhenaten
to make such drastic
changes during a time
of tremendous prosperity?
Ancient astronaut theorists
suggest there may have
been an otherworldly influence.
And as evidence, point to
the way he was depicted
by artists of the time.
Akhenaten cannot introduce
the idea that every
time his artisans
would carve something,
it had to be lifelike.
So it had to be represented
exactly the way it was seen.
Which is interesting
because if you
look at the likenesses
of Akhenaten,
he looks very strange.
Akhenaten had himself depicted
in the most peculiar way.
He had this elongated face.
He had this protruding belly.
He had these almost like,
chicken leg type legs.
Very peculiar.
With this elongated
skull at the back.
Now all of the pharaohs
have themselves
depicted looking
as, shall we say,
majestic and
muscular as possible.
One has to wonder if
Akhenaten may have been
some type of an
extraterrestrial hybrid,
and that is why he
introduced this one god rule.
Perhaps that sun disk Aten
that Akhenaten prayed to
wasn't a sun in the
sky at all, but it
could have been an
extraterrestrial
that's instructed Akhenaten.
The texts say it's
a winged disk.